So let's look at the solution
to our RAID1 quiz.
We have a RAID1 array with two disks.
A single disk in this array is
a 200GB disk with a throughput of
10MB/s and an MTTF = 100,000h.
And when a disk fails we replace it and
it takes us 24h to do that.
So, in a two-disk RAID1, the data
capacity is the same as for one disk.
That's because both disks
are storing exactly the same data,
which allows us to survive
the failure of one disk.
The throughput, when we are reading,
is twice the throughput of a single
disk because we can issue reads
to both disks at the same time.
But when we are writing,
we are writing to both disks at once.
So the throughput for
writing is only 10MB/s.
If half of the requests are reads and
the other half of the requests
are writes, then in any given second,
we will be spending one-third
of a second on the reads and
we will be spending two-thirds
of a second on the writes.
That way, we get to do the same number
of reads and writes per second.
It's just that the reads
are twice as fast, so
they take half the time of
the writes in that same second.
In the one-third of a second
that we have been doing reads,
we were getting a 20MB/s throughput
because we were using both disks.
In the two-thirds of a second
when we were doing writes,
we were getting only 10MB/s.
So overall during this one
second using the raid one array,
we ended up getting
a throughput of 40 over 3MB,
which gives us
a throughput of 13.33MB/s,
because in one second,
we managed to access 40 over 3MB.
So the answer here is 13.33.
Note that the throughput is not 15MB/s,
which is what we would get if we
simply average the read throughput and
the write throughput we
would get in this array.
Because if we did this,
we are assuming that for
a half a second we are reading and then
for half a second we are writing, and
thus we get 15 MB read and
written in a second.
But if for half a second, we read and
for half a second we write.
We end up reading twice the amount
of data that we would for writes.
So if the workload is 50-50 in terms
of number of accesses, then it's
not also 50-50 in terms of time spent
on reads and time spent of writes.
Reads are faster,
thus we spent less time on them,
which is why again
the throughput is not 15MB/s.
And finally, let us figure out
the MTTF for the entire RAID1 array.
The MTTF of a whole RAID1
array with two disks, we set,
is equal to the MTTF of
a single disc divided by two.
So this is how long we have to
operate with two discs until
one of the discs fails.
And now each time we have a one disc
failure, we need to repair it and
we said that the number of
times we can try a repair
until we finally experience a failure
of the second disc during the repair of
the first disc is MTTF of one disk
divided by the MTTR of the disc.
So this first factor
will be 50,000 hours.
The second factor is the ratio of the
time to failure and the time to repair.
And when we divide these
two we get 4166.666 etc.
So this is how many times can we try
a repair while a single disk is working
until we finally experience a repair
in which the working disk also fails.
And when we multiply this out
we get 208,333,333 hours.
So this is a huge amount of time
compared to the original disks MTTF.
As you can see RAID1 dramatically
improves reliability.
This time is about 11 years.
This time is about 24,000 years.
So as you can see,
the reliability has improved from being
able to expect data loss every about
10ish years to something that goes
into tens of thousands of years.